on a personal level i truly believe that
all my characters
they choose me i get to be an instrument
and a voice for people that are
marginalized or
go unheard or who feel voiceless people
like that come from the same community i
was born and raised in
and i know what that feels like because
i felt like that before
[Music]
omar davon little came to me by way of
an audition there was a time prior to
that i had just
started out as a budding actor getting
little bit parts
throughout new york city and the process
had slowed up for me
in regards to booking work and i had to
earn a living so i opted out of
hollywood i thought that my career had
you know run its course
in this process i get to do two things i
get to be
this conduit for information and for an
experience
and i take that with a badge of honor um
the other thing that that i get to do is
i get to heal i get to have these
characters show me parts of myself
that i can fix or make better or get rid
of
or just take a look at and particularly
with omar
he was fearless he was outspoken
you don't need to open this door man if
i huff and puff
come on now by the here's your chinny
chin chin you best roll out
you're up in here he suffered
not even a little bit from social
acceptability
you know he didn't care what anyone
thought about him except
the ones he loved and he had a huge
moral compass
and he wasn't afraid to express it i was
the complete polar opposite
i was frightened a lot of times growing
up i had a very
low self-esteem and a huge need to be
accepted
the only thing that i i knew that i
shared with all my was his sensitivity
and his ability to love and his ability
to love deep
i knew that i had that in me let me tell
y'all something
all right what i do i do
straight like that so ain't no sense
y'all even troubling yourselves over
that because man the way i feel right
now today
in a lot of ways that character became
like my superman suit
i would put omar on man i just felt like
invincible
like i can do anything i don't think
i've ever had a relationship with a
character
like that in my career the way i did
with omar when the show ended
and um it was time to put the cape away
that didn't bode well with me
i had to find out what it's like to
release a character
to say goodbye to her job
when i booked chalky white i had lost my
way a little bit personally
and i was overseas in africa i just at
one point didn't think that
it was healthy for me to stay out there
and work
because i was um just getting tripped up
a little too much
and i asked for a sign and that sign
came to me
by way of chalky white so i still didn't
believe it you know i was like this is
too good to be true i told my agent and
she was like well
if you don't put their name in a hat you
won't even have a chance at winning this
lottery and i was like okay
and i sent it in and marty cast me
you are i assume mr white may i say it
is both an honor
and a privilege to be making your
acquaintance
[ __ ] are you short pants my relationship
with chalky was
was different um you know it only had
omar
and characters from that told the urban
experience or or the experience of what
i knew
growing up as a black man in brooklyn
chucky white took me outside of that
comfort zone
i had to go deeper in my exploration of
the
the black experience um in america and
i didn't have anyone that was alive
or walked to earth in those times that i
could go to
to converse with i remember hearing
denzel washington
in an interview say that he uses
his ancestors to get in touch with his
characters
and i thought that was brilliant and i
gave it a shot
so what i did was um i looked at all the
characteristics of this character
the many faces his his personality i
summed them up
into five five basic personalities
and then i went into my rolodex of
family members that i knew of men that i
knew that
lived that era that were no longer here
and i paired those characteristics
with the characteristics of these loved
ones in my family it's his soft side
with his children that reminded me of
my uncle jehu his sarcastic
you know kind of coy side reminded me of
my uncle tommy
the way he dressed the way he peacocked
in his clothing and
that snarl and that that walk of
confidence
that came from my godfather the way he
was with the ladies
um that was my i was my dad
my dad was a bit of a rolling stone with
the ladies uh
last but not least that ability that
rage that can drive him to kill a man
with his bare hands
in five minutes that was my uncle paul
it worked out beautifully
come down here looking for an army yes
ain't that [ __ ] something fine cause i
ain't heard one people now
this isn't the time for hurt feelings i
ain't saying nothing about how i feel
like you ain't saying nothing [ __ ] jump
boy
jack g was a huge uh accomplishment for
me in my career one because it uh it
enabled me for the opportunity
i had wanted for a lifetime to work with
my my good friend and little sister
um dana but the rest of the world knows
her as queen latifah
i've known dana since she was 17 years
old we've always been friends
and considered family i knew that i
always wanted to work with her on
some capacity i mean i would have
carried this chick's bags if she would
have hired me
so when i got the role of jack gio the
opportunity to play jack g i jumped at
it i loved the fact that she didn't
offer me the role
i loved the fact that i had to audition
for it and i had to earn it it was a
testament to our friendship that i
needed to earn her respect as an
artist and not have it feel like she was
doing me a favor
and that was the process that i took to
get it
that's just going on
okay we going we're going now
right now but sing one song honey
the way you like it don't sing it for me
damn nobody you singing for yourself
now what you say in creating the
character of jack g
it was a challenge for me because he
lived
in the same era as chalky white
and not only that i was filming them at
the same time
so i i really worked hard to
distinguish them why you went to ask me
first
see if i was ready well i'm ready
i want a real family not no road family
i want the whole thing you know a big
house
and everybody in it well everybody ain't
gonna be in it if you don't start
showing me some respect
i remember early on uh when people would
ask me
are you afraid of being typecast aren't
you i was like
i worry about not eating this is my job
i mean why would i
care about typecasting i'm a black man i
tell black experience in america like
like what like this is
this is this is what it is and then i
realized
that it is my job to see to it
that i am not stereotyped just because i
may play the same genre
of of story tell the same genre of story
the same genre of narrative
doesn't mean that these people are
stereotyped just because
you and i came from the same hood um
are both black males both came from
broken homes
we could have both even had similar
experiences
with making bad choices that does not
mean that you and i are statistically
the same
when we do that we we put numbers on
people as opposed to
the individual human experience uh was
or
is and so that was the main thing i
needed to do
with jack g was um do the research of
who he was
he was a real person and to make sure
that he stood up he stood apart
from my portrayal of chalky white
i was really excited to be working on
this once again
in the presence of greatness comedic
improv greatness i had never been
so nurtured in a process before the way
i was on
on the spoils it was clear that i was
the weakest link in the chain in regards
to
comedic timing and improv they created a
scenario in this writing
for me to come in and do what i do which
is play the serious note and
the laughter happened around me the
laughter was
the irony that was in this situation in
the storyline
rock with strings just you
poor alistair he's been trying to get me
to make a
jasmine strings album for years rock
bandian was fighting
for his art and to not be manipulated
and to not
be sold out to not have his soul be
bought
give me some time i could i could prove
my innocence i i maybe i could do
something i
could i could find something out i mean
what have you got to lose maybe you
would skip town
with this mug everyone knows me where am
i gonna hide
i believe these are things that we as
artists deal with
in real life that people deal with in
real life
and to have that narrative as it
pertains to
you know myself and hollywood
and you know the type of roles that i
chose to take and and how i pursue how i
pursue
my characters and how i create them
there was a little bit of that
in the storytelling of rock band and i
was very grateful to have that
opportunity but
mostly to i could say man to work with
kristen wiig
and kate mckinnon maya rudolph jesus
christ
yeah those three ladies i grew on that
set
um having worked with them they were
such pros
and the timing i i'd never seen nothing
like that
the way they could just improv and come
in and out of it and
it was brilliant and um i learned a lot
on that set
yeah the night of was a tough but
brilliant experience
in creating freddie knight you know
steve zillion he's
pretty masterful at creating this this
tension
what we say sometimes is the unwritten
word so what he wanted to do was take
the audience through
the feeling of doing time how much time
is just taken being processed
being sent to jail then having to get to
get processed to go to prison
you know being in prison the
ramifications of the day-to-day
of being incarcerated it seems like time
is just
standing still and he wanted to bring
the audience into that
that was a really grueling and tough
process
you know um the sets we were literally
in prison
the base camp looked like the yard there
was nothing glamorous about this set
look at that cell phone business bruh i
ain't got no cell phone business i don't
know what you're talking about
i must have heard wrong man
come on freddy i told you i know what
you're talking about that one cell phone
even the route i would take to get to
work
i took was the same route that i would
take to go see my nephew
dominic dupont when he was incarcerated
he's home now but
it was doing the filming of this that i
got a glimpse into
what his life must be like and what his
life was like for 20 years
it made me really sad that you know
there are people
in our society that are forced to live
like this i'm not saying that you
shouldn't be made to pay for your
mistakes
but when is when is enough enough and
when is a a person
deserving of a second chance and we got
to look at all the things that go wrong
with our justice system
in the night of and knowing that i have
family members that have fallen prey to
this
it was discouraging
leaving a character like freddie knight
on the night oven
and going to ken jones on when we rise
was a huge shift in the opposite
direction
so you know freddie he was he was dark
he was he was he had a lot of issues he
was tormented
it was a lot of potential lost with
freddie freddie could have been a lot of
things
and then here i go to to ken jones
who in a lot of ways ken jones was
an american hero i mean he had survived
so many wars he was on you know on the
front lines
of what it was like to be black in the
navy in the
late 60s early 70s and the amount of
racism he must have dealt with
then also having to hide the fact that
he was
secretly in love with uh another white
soldier
and the trauma of having this man his
love of his life meet his demise because
of him something he
he had done so by the time he leaves the
navy he has all this trauma he survived
so much
only to be put back on the front line
of gay rights and and to survive
the plague that we now know to be hiv
aids
it's been so much bad done in the name
of god
i can assure you this is not that god
to where he is today in his life with
you know order dana minister that that
marries people
it was just such an opportunity to tell
a story of
triumph and of and overcoming
adversity
yeah you know happened leonard was a bit
of a first for me was the first time
that i
been asked to uh gotten the opportunity
to lead a show
and with that came some perks um i had
to say so in
a part to doing the decision making of
who gets to be
my hap and um i really pushed to get
james
um on the project i knew that he had
just wrapped his uh
his second season of a show he was doing
on fox and
i really i begged him tooth and nail to
come and be a part of this family with
me and take this journey
because of the writing and the world
that that happened that it lived in
james and i already had that banter and
we talked
on similar issues like that and we had
opposing opinions and we would agree to
disagree
at times and um there was no one else
that could have taken this journey
uh you know creating leonard
it was a lot of fun he was a walking
contradiction
you know he was a black cowboy who was
openly gay
and a republican it was like what he
liked country music
huh what wait wait wait wha what is this
i need to bring your guns with you
i thought you didn't like my girl what
kind of time can you get here i told you
i had to mull it over now let me move
well don't mow too long the maltese as
long as the mold takes
i just found him fun and interesting and
to be able to have a narrative
a two characters one black one white and
to show that these two men
can still have if not the same
a very similar human experience i think
uh happened leonard spoke to the
classism that plagues
us as a community as as well too and it
was just interesting to tell these
narratives
to tell a a story that took place in the
middle of the country
you know it's not a city it's not a
coast a very
new experience for me on a number of
reasons um
we shot happen leonard in atlanta uh
well
nearly in georgia or for any person
that's black once we leave the
safe confines of the city of atlanta
you are brutally reminded that you are
in a red
state on the way to work i would see the
confederate flag up and down
in people's yards and the highways on in
windows james and i had to go to work
november 3rd 2016.
ring a bell and
you could cut the tension with a knife
on the set
i just remember not wanting to be quiet
not wanting to act as if i don't see
this elephant in the room
i huddled everybody crew and cast
together
and i said guys come on let's let's not
bring this energy
here we're so blessed i said look around
look at our office
we're in the middle of the forest the
trees were we're falling turning all
types of colors look where we get to
look at all this natural beauty we get
to call
all this nature our office i said look
how we're working together
right here with black white you know
male female gay straight young old
and we all working together for one
common goal to create
art i said that's the gift of art it
transcends
all of these ignorant scenarios that we
create in this outside world
so let's leave that crap out there and
let's focus on
the artists that we all are and let's
create this narrative
that can hopefully change that crap out
there
not become part of that and that was the
first time that i had the opportunity to
do something like that
when they see us was a huge like had to
have it in my in my career one because
i'm from brooklyn new york and i
remember when that was happening
and two i could have easily been swept
up in that number
because for obvious reasons i was a
black man living in new york city and
two because i was at risk
you know unlike the five men i was
really out there so um
i jumped at the opportunity to tell
their story
you left you know how you get mud on
your pants bro
i i was running
the police
are you trying to tell me all you always
running from the police
come on charlie we talked about this man
bro you know better than that i taught
you better than that right
in creating bobby mcrae i knew that
he had made some bad choices i know he
loved his family but i also know that he
made a very bad choice he got going when
the going got tough
that's fact that is law and that cannot
be changed
however i had the opportunity to speak
with a mrs mcrae we spoke for like two
hours
i know now that she was on her sick bed
you know
she died shortly thereafter of
pancreatic cancer so mrs mcrae never got
to see when they see us however she gave
us two hours of her time and her energy
to explain what it was like back then
for her
and her relationship to her husband and
all this time
she never once referred to anything else
except
either her husband or the father of her
child
she never once spoke about any sort of
disappointment or anger towards him
only empathy and love and understanding
in fact one time i had to like put the
phone down
i didn't want to hear me like you know
sniffling she says you know i really
believe that we were so
happy as a family that we didn't make
space for god
and so he had to take my family to make
to it was one of the most painful things
i heard anyone saying it just it broke
my heart
after i finished talking to her i
realized that i had to go deeper
to find bobby mcrae that i owed it to
her
to not just depict him as he was on
paper
although that was true there had to be a
reason why i had to go look for the
reason why
[Music]
look when the police want what they want
they will do anything
do you hear me and for me it related to
this proverb and it says if a man
cannot protect and provide for his
family
then what is left of a man when i
related that to bobby mcrae
it made me realize how how much
they used his words and his past with
the justice system
they weaponized that and they used it
against him when he realized that that
he had made choices
out of fear and ignorance that almost
could have killed his son or that took
his son away from him
i think the shame and the guilt of that
reality
made him believe that his family was
better off without him
and when i hit that note on the piano
key that was one of the most painful the
most jagged pills i had to swallow as
being
a father myself what that must feel like
with the responses i've gotten from
people
particularly on the streets of new york
city particularly the young people
i was riding my bike the other day and i
had a group of young brothers
and they walked by and they walked back
and then they walked by again and one
kick is
bobby mcrae and i was like whoa
i mean just like straight you know so
that let me know that they were watching
that also lets me know that they are
asking the question
how did this happen and once that
question gets asked
the possibilities are endless so i know
that um
this narrative of when they see us has
definitely
changed the culture afforded the
movement for equality and for and for
justice reform
it is definitely definitely put a
huge spotlight on all the hard
dedicated work that the innocent project
puts into stories like this
for real though not in hollywood
building montrose freeman it was kind of
like
all of the characters of my career in
one shot manchos
embodies bits of omar bits of chalky
bits of freddie knight bits of ken jones
bits of bobby mcrae it all comes to a
head
with montrose freeman hey mondrose
what the hell y'all doing here we're
here to save you
my favorite damn self this character
really stretched me i almost thought i
was going to snap
at times um telling these stories
the relationship between father and son
in my community
is so sacred it's endangered
for a number of reasons uh whether it be
mass incarceration
drug addiction all around poverty the
family structure has been
has been it's frayed right now and in
particular between
father and son a lot of our young men
are left home to be raised by their moms
or by the women in the family
or by the police department in the
neighborhood
and to be able to show a father-son
relationship
as it relates to black men in my
community
on top of all the social ills that that
has been
placed on us it was a huge
opportunity to show the complexities
of what it means to be black and male
in america that is what montrose freeman
brought to me he came with all of these
things to the table that i had to
unpack and dissect and in that
was my generational trauma and a real
real big mirror for me to look at and
see myself
what is broken and wrong with me in
regards to the way i respond to things
it was all there you don't even talk to
him like that i talk to myself however
the hell i want to there was no plan b
i was so lost as a young man growing up
when the arts found me i was pretty lost
if the arts had not found me at that
crucial time in my life
i don't think i'd be here the way art
saved my life
for me the only way for me to say
thank you is by making sure i pass the
torch
is by making sure that the foundation
that i am standing on
is strong enough to support
the next person that will stand on these
two shoulders and that's what this is
about for me